Ja, oh everybody, das Podcast UFO, Fluentine ist am Start, das Podcast UFO, Stefan Tietzel ist auch dabei. Drei hundert sechsen sechzig, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Vielen Dank fürs Rumkommen, vielen Dank fürs Rumkommen auch an dich, Florian Will, sitzt mir gegenüber und grinst mich an. Natürlich, dass wir euch auf diese staubige Road to Infinity gesetzt haben, denn der Horizont ist unsere Heimat. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Zum Thema Tonarten von Sweet Home Alabama, Darian schreibt, wir haben hier einen C9-Akkord, welcher in einer der beiden Tonarten vorkommt. Man spricht von einem plagialen Schluss, da C die Subdominante zur Tonika G bildet. Selbst wenn das Stück also in D stehen würde, dann würde er im Schluss von G in D einen plagialen Schluss bilden, was D wiederum die Subdominante ist. Das Intervall G zu Zester gegenüber... Mama, ich habe das Gefühl, dem Sprecher ist das auch ganz egal. Ich habe das Gefühl, dem Sprecher dieses Galileo-Beitrags ist ihr Beitrag auch komplett egal. Und der C, der vulkanische Aktivität... Die vulkanische Aktivität... Hat er gerade gerustet? Hat er gerade während des Beitrags gerustet? Ist dem Cutter das auch alles egal? Ist allen alles egal? Schatz, du bist das einzige Kind, das sich für Vulkan interessiert. Alle anderen sagen, mein Gott, die ruhen, die schlafen doch seit Jahren. Aber die können doch jede Zeit explodieren.
Nein. Tanz auf dem Vulkan.
Ist doch fantastisch. Jederzeit
in der Sprache der Steine
heißt alle tausend Jahre mal, wenn es hochkommt.
Vulkan heißt
möglicherweise gleich explodierender
Superberg, Zauberberg.
Mama, es ist doch was Besonderes.
Lava. Wir gehen jetzt zum
Vesuv und wenn der nicht in fünf Minuten explodiert, dann sagst du,, interessierst du dich für was anderes. Seitdem ihr bei TikTok abhängt, Mama und Papa, seid ihr super irgendwie so ungeduldig mit der Natur und so. Ist doch schön. Allein der Gedanke, dass sie gleich explodieren können, die Berge. Ich wünsche mir nichts sehnlicher, als dass ihr endlich mal euer Handy weglegt und zum Vesuv mit mir geht. Und vorbei. N explodiert. Oh mein Gott, kein Like, zwei Sterne, Vesuv, ein Stern. Gross, aber nicht explodiert. Gibt es hundertprozentig beim Vesuv die User-Bewertung, nicht ausgebrochen, nicht ausgebrochen, riesen Enttäuschung, eins von fünf Sternen. Ja, oder das Gegenteil, ausgebrochen, manntot, eins von fünf Sternen. Und dann schreibt so der Organisator, ja Leute, was wollt ihr? Ja, so. Also ich habe hier eine Einster Einstellebewertung für ausgebrochen, eine für nicht ausgebrochen. I'm getting mixed signals. Man kann es nicht allen recht machen. Die Leute wollen Pompeji sehen, aber nicht sterben. Okay, gut, das müssen wir irgendwie zusammenbringen. Die Leute wollen mit Haien schwimmen, aber nicht sterben. Ja, okay, entscheidet euch Leute. Hallo? Alles klar. Die Leute wollen eine leckere Pizza essen, aber keine Lebensmittelvergiftung. Aber nicht sterben. Also, Leute, ich bin hier zwischen den Stühlen. Due, äh, intra de due, ähm, sedas. Sedas, intras de sedas, was weiss ich denn, ey. Seit zwei Wochen lerne ich nicht mehr bei Duolingo Italienisch alles vergessen. Wieso ist das so? Ich glaube, die Schule hat mein, und jetzt möchte ich an das Kultusministerium da draußen, Bildungsministerium appellieren. Die Schulsysteme da draußen machen aus Gehirnen Kurzzeitgedächtnisse à la par excellence. Und das ist schrecklich. Ich habe keine, wenn ich irgendwas, ich bin dann in einer Phase oder ich gucke eine Doku, in dem Moment weiss ich alles darüber, nächstes Tag könnte ich einen Test schreiben, easy, sehr gut, aber drei Wochen später schon nicht mehr. Jetzt ist alles weg, was ich im Italienischen jemals gelernt habe mit Duolingo. Ja, es ist wirklich, es gibt ja Leute, die sofort, wenn sie irgendwas nicht mehr brauchen, sofort verkaufen, weg, kann das weg.
Ich glaube, ich bin wie so ein Hund. Ich bin eher ein Hund. Sobald ich in einer anderen Situation bin, weiss ich schon nicht mehr, was vorher in der Situation war. Und auch Gefühle weiss ich dann nicht mehr. Ich weiss dann, wenn ich etwas Neuem ausgesetzt bin, ist das mein neues Zuhause. Ja, deswegen, bei mir ist ja ein grosser Teil des Tages damit beschäftigt, dass ich aufwache und dann überlege, was weiß ich eigentlich noch. Was ist noch da? Das habe ich gemacht, als ich auf die Fresse gefallen bin mit dem Schüsselbein und dann noch Platzwunden oben hatte. Einfach mal Stichprobenartig ein paar Bilder von Pokémon angucken. Was weiß ich noch? Snobili-Cut, ist Snobili-Cut noch da oder ist genau das der Cut? Ist genau Snobili-Cut das der Cut, wo alles weggeworfen wurde? Das ist das eine Pokémon, was ich, glaube ich, eh nie kannte. Nee. Braucht man nicht. Nee, braucht man nicht. Ist das die Weiterentwicklung von Mautz? Von Mautz, genau. Richtig. Schau mal, schau mal. Ja. Ich habe jetzt erfahren, dass Uri Geller ja eine Pokémonkarte weggeklagt hat, nämlich ich glaube, Kadabra. Oh, mit dem Löffel oder was? Genau, weil Kadabra, also im Deutschen heißt es ja Abra, die erste Entwicklungsstufe, dann Kadabra die zweite und Simsalah die dritte. Und Kadabra hat dann den Löffel in der Hand, Simsalah hat dann zwei Löffel in der Hand, also es geht steilbergauf mit den Löffeln. Also die Logik stimmt absolut, 0, 1, 2. Die Löffelanzahl nimmt hinzu linear zur Entwicklungsstufe. Deswegen gab es auch nie ein Bim-Pokémon, weil du nicht sagen könntest, der hat dann drei Löffel oder was. Geht's ja nicht weiter.
Da muss man auch drei Hände haben.
Ja, was soll das?
Hier ist vorbei, hier ist vorbei.
Aber im japanischen Original heissen die nicht Arbokadaver und Simsa da, wäre das gedacht, sondern die dritte Entwicklungsstufe heisst Houdini und die zweite ist Urigella, aber eher so Urigella, also so leicht verändert, aber es ist sehr...
Aber als Hans Glock einfach. Ja, genau. Nee, nee, Ehrlich Brothers. Ehrlich Brothers. Dann Uri Geller und dann Houdini. Und er hat das gesehen, er hat dann das Pokémon gesehen und gesagt, ja, aber Leute, ich meine, das ist mein Löffeltrick.
Das ist mein Löffeltrick.
Das ist meine Löffelillusion.
Ich meine, Zauberei.
Das ist meine Löffelzauberei.
Und das ist ja ganz klar ich.
Bin ja ganz klar ich, weil das ist ja mein Name.
Im japanischen Gut, aber...
Da kann ja jeder kommen.
Da kann ja jeder kommen und dann sagen, ich bin Mirapla.
Es könnte jeder, so jeder Dachs könnte kommen und sagen, ich bin Pikachu. Ist Pikachu eine Ratte? Eine Maus. Eine Maus. Eine Maus, okay. Jede Maus könnte sagen, das bin ja ich. Ja, bin ich. Das stimmt. Ich glaube, in Japan dürfen auch Tiere klagen. Deswegen dachten die, scheiße, schliesst es die Tür vom Gerichtssaal ab. Die dürfen nicht rein. Jetzt hat er eine Enkeltochter und die ist gross großer Pokémon-Fan, und jetzt hat er die Klage endlich aufgehoben, und jetzt darf diese Karte wieder produziert werden. Shoutout! Urigela? Okay, Shoutout an Urigela. Dass er die Klage endlich hat fallen lassen, und das ganze Gericht so in Japan. Oh, endlich haben wir keinen Zauberer mehr gegen uns. Die ganze Angst, ständig verschwinden unsere Autos. Leute, ich habe mir gerade einen Kaffee gemacht und die Löffel sind nicht mehr verbogen. Die Löffel sind nicht mehr verbogen. Wirklich? Der Fluch ist gebrochen. Wir können endlich unsere Zottmontes ganz normal essen wie normale Menschen. Ist irgendwas passiert und so einer, ja Uri Geller hat die Klage aufgehoben. Och, Gott sei Dank, alle Löffel waren verbogen. Ich habe angefangen, irgendwann meinen Zottmonte mit dem Messer zu essen, wie so ein Idiot. Ich habe es versucht, mit der Gabel zu essen und dann so ganz schnell, das ist bevor das runterrinnt, zwischen den Zacken, dass ich es noch im Mund habe. Und das hat einem auch nicht mehr geschmeckt, wenn es so schnell ist. Nee, aber ich bin so froh, dass diese Löffel nicht mehr verbogen sind. Nimm mal so nach vorne. Ich meine, er hat einen sauschlechten Anwalt gehabt, aber halt diesen Löffeltrick. Juri Geller. Willst du wirklich dafür bekannt sein, am Ende deines Lebens, dass du den Löffel verbiegen kannst? Naja, er wollte ja auch die Atombomben, die Putin angedroht hat, umlenken oder sowas. Zu verbiegen. Das war das Letzte, was man von ihm gehört hat. Also, ach, Uri Geller ist so ein Phänomen, finde ich. Weil das war das Letzte, was man gehört hat und das Neueste ist halt, er hat diese Klage gegen das Pokémon Kadabra. War eine wilde Woche, war eine wilde Woche, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Also, was hat er für ein Leben? für ein Leben? Da war der Wochenplan voll, randvoll,
japanisches Gericht.
Wie wohnt Uri Geller?
Hat der auch so ein Vertigo-Poster,
so ein Hitchcock-Poster an der Wand hängen?
Der schläft dann in so einem Holzkasten,
wo man dann so durchsägen kann, aber er schläft da drin.
Alles einfach nur Magie.
Wahnsinn, wir wissen, wie ist der eingerichtet?
Hat der Stühle auf der...
Welche Stühle kauft Uri Geller? Hat er so Freischwinger?
Ich glaube, Uri Geller kauft gar nichts. Uri Geller geht in Ikea und wirft so ein schwarzes Tuch über so einen Stuhl und sagt dann, der weite Gatorade.
Er hat Steimschalosch. Genau, so zack und dann ist der Stuhl weg und bei ihm im Auto im Fiat Punto hinten im Kofferraum eingeklemmt.
Oder man geht raus und der Ikea ist in einem anderen Land oder sowas. Oh Mann, ey. Papa. Uri. Ist Uri kurz eigentlich für irgendeinen Urigolon oder so? Orentaton. Orentaton. Orentaton. So ein aus dem Himmel gefallener Engel oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja, genau, richtig. Der Löffelverbiegende. Der, der den Löffel biegt, der einst aus dem Himmel stürzt. Stefan ist ja der Gekränzte, also der mit einem Siegeskranz versehene, und Urigella ist der, den Löffelverbiegende. Und Florentin ist der aus Florenz. Tatsächlich mal mein Lateinlehrer gesagt, der hat es immer genossen, uns zu quälen vor der Abfrage und meinte dann, der wusste dann immer die Wortbedeutung von allen und dann immer so, ah, heute kommt mal an die Tafel der Blühende. Ach Gott, und niemand ist aufgeschlagen. Claudia, Estefania, Amon, Rainer, Götz, Götz, der Florentin. Dammit. Nochmal. Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Aber Florenz oder nicht? Florenz. Kann auch sein, ja. Der aus Florenz stammende. Oder Florenz wurde nach den Florentinern benannt, ein Adelsgeschlecht von Blühenden. Der blühende Stamm. Die Blühende. Aber ich glaube, Blühende ist auch so ein bisschen so, der blüht noch auf. Also, da kommt noch wasstanden. Die Vergänglichkeit ist auch mit drin. Er verblüht auch. Kann man verblühen? Klar. Kann man sich wirklich verblühen? Dass so eine Rose sich einfach ich hab's übertrieben, ich hab mich komplett verblüht einfach. Du bist blau. Was? Du bist blau. Oh nein, ich hab mich das nicht verblüht. Ach, der hat mich komplett verblüht. Der Dresscode war doch rot, oder nicht? Ja, ich hab dir gesagt gestern, du warst viel zu nervös, du hast viel zu überzogen, du hast die ganze Nacht gelernt und so, dass es sich verblüht. Heute ist doch das grosse Rosenfest der Rosenzüchter und ich bin blau. Du bist blau. Ja, was mach ich denn jetzt? Ist das ein Traum? Stich mich mal. Okay, ich stich dich kurz mit meiner Dorne. Ach nein, es ist kein Traum. Ich glaube, es ist eine blaue Rose, hätte ich tatsächlich Lust. Nee, verblühen ja voll, gibt es bestimmt auch. Ich habe, früher war ich ja nicht so cool wie heute, aber hauptsächlich Warhammer-Fantasy-Figuren bemalt. Okay. So kleine Plastikritter, die ich bemalt habe. Und dann stand aber, dann hatte ich so Ritter, also wirklich Ritter auf dem Pferd. Und dann stand da, ja, es gibt so sieben verschiedene Orden in der Welt mit ihren Wappen. Und dann stand aber noch in diesem Buch, das man dazu kauft, stand da noch so ein Satz, sie können aber auch ihre eigenen Orden sich ausdenken und ein eigenes Wappen gestalten. Da dachte ich natürlich, ja klar, mache ich sofort, genial. Das ist über das Schalke-Logo draufgemacht. Ich mache meinen eigenen Ritterorden, wie oft hat man die Möglichkeiten. Also selbst die mächtigsten Könige können selten komplette Orden gründen, ich dachte mir, geil, mache ich das natürlich sofort. Also habe ich gegründet den Orden der schwarzen Rose. Fand ich sehr cool. Fand ich richtig cool. Schwarz ist eine coole Farbe, Rose ist von den Blumen wahrscheinlich noch das, was ein 16-jähriger Junge am ehesten. Da kamst du auch aus deinem blühenden? Nee, das hat glaube ich damit nichts zu tun, aber interessante, interessante Diagramm. Und dann habe ich da so eine Rose extrem schwer zu malen, eine Rose auf dem Wappen, du musst dann da so die Linien der Kanten, aber habe ich einigermaßen hingekriegt. Das ist ja auch winzig klein, diese Ritterschild. Super klein. Und dann dachte ich mir, geil, jetzt habe ich einen richtig coolen Orden und dann gehe ich zu meinen Freunden und sage, Leute, übrigens, ich wollte nur mal sagen, ich habe jetzt für meine Armee des Imperiums, habe ich jetzt einen Ritterorden gemacht, und zwar der Orden der Schwarzen Rose. Ja, aber ich weiß ja gar nicht, was die Angriffspunkte sind und die Verteidigungspunkte von diesen, also. Na, die sind ja immer gleich, aber ich wollte einfach nur ein bisschen. Und ich habe denen gesagt. Es macht keinen Spaß, mit dir zu spielen, Floretti. Mir geht es ja nur um die Ästhetik. Und ich habe denen gesagt, ja, mein Orden heißt Ritter der Schwarzen Rose. Und meine Freunde haben mich ausgelacht. Okay. Mich richtig hart ausgelacht. Okay. Und haben gesagt, was ist das denn für ein bescheuerter Name, schreiben mir heute noch Mails, dass sie sagen, was ist das für eine dumme Idee. Ich hab schon ein paar Mal gesagt, blockier doch diesen Bain-Adressen. Und ich dachte mir, hä, warum ist das uncool, schwarze Rose ist doch mega cool. Also ich war wirklich, ich dachte mein komplettes cooles Weltbild ist kaputt, weil, also, das kann doch nicht sein. Und dann dachte ich, war ich zu Hause und hatte schon drei Ritter bemalt und dachte mir, was soll ich jetzt machen, soll ich die jetzt wieder umbemalen? Ich dachte mir, nee, das muss deren Problem sein, die haben den falschen Coolness-Sensor, weil Schwarz ist cool. Selten für Kinder ist quasi der Gedanke, ah nee, nee, die sind falsch. Ja, aber ich bin es nochmal durchgegangen im Kopf, wenn man jetzt gesagt hätte, irgendwie die gelbe Tulpe oder so. Okay, wieso? Aber gelb ist, sag ich mal, eher eine Anlassfarbe und nicht eine Coolnessfarbe. Gelb trägt auf. Genau, und ich, schwarze Rose, und dann dachte ich mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Und beim nächsten Mal hatte ich die Figuren dann dabei, haben wir gespielt, und dann habe ich gesagt, ah ja, hier, cool, guck mal hier, meine Figuren, Ritter der schwarzen Rose. Und er meinte, ach so Rose. Wir haben... Der schwarze Hose. Wir haben Hose verstanden. Nein. Und ich dachte mir, ah. Nein. Die haben gesagt, die Ritter der schwarzen Hose und die lachen sich kaputt und ich bin völlig am Boden zerstört. Zwei Wochen lang, das kann doch nicht sein. Aber die haben mich einfach auf einen Versprecher ausgelacht. Und jetzt denkt man natürlich zurück, wo habe ich mich... Und dann waren sich alle einig, schwarze Rose coolste Namen. Ja genau, alle sagten, ja, mega cool. Aber gut, dass du da einfach so straight geblieben bist. Ja, zum Glück habe ich es hingegangen. Also das macht ja niemand. Mein Ratschlag an euch, wenn ihr irgendwie gedemütigt oder fertig gemacht wird für irgendwas, vielleicht ist es einfach falsch verstanden. Also vielleicht geht es gar nicht darum, was ihr macht, sondern dass die Leute es einfach akustisch leicht falsch verstanden haben und es gar nicht uncool ist. Jetzt muss ich aber sagen, ich finde Dritter der schwarzen Hose nicht den schlechtesten Namen. Das Problem ist halt, du musst halt immer das Wappen vor dir haben. Viel einfacher zu malen. Als Taschen? Mittlerliche Hosen sind schwer, die haben ja noch so vorne diese Falte. Wie diese Falte? Du machst eine komische Handbewegung.
Ich glaube, die haben keinen klassischen
Hosenstein, sondern die haben dann noch mal
so einen Lappen, der von unten oben hochgeknüpft.
Das sieht manchmal auch ein bisschen bescheuert aus.
Um schnell runterzuknöpfen.
Genau, wenn es schnell gehen muss.
Wenn du während der Schlacht denkst,
ich habe zu viel Met getrunken
und ich trete kurz aus, ich komme gleich wieder. Und der Gegner so, ah, okay, Spielstopp. Spielstopp. Wie beim, es gibt ja beim Lab, beim Live-Action-Rollplay, gibt es ja dieses Zeichen, dass man so die Hände gekreuzt auf die Brust legt. Ein Safe-Gesture. Genau, und das heißt, ich bin gerade nicht in Character. Okay. Also das heißt, wenn du, du, ich bin der schwarze Ritter und ich bin gekommen, um deine Haare und gut gut an mich zu riechen. Sorry, ich muss kurz aufs Klo. Alles klar. Und dann muss er woanders hingehen. Da kannst du alles abhängen. Und deswegen ist er beim Lab auch nicht wirklich drin in der Welt, weil du kannst jeder Zeit sagen. Weil die Falle ja nicht stimmt. Das heißt, wenn du dir gerade die Zähne putzt und jemand kommt und sagt, was ist das denn für eine alchemistische Tinktur, die sie da und du nur so, ich bin, ich putze gerade die Zähne. Aber wie oft macht man das, weil man keinen Bock hat. Angenommen, er meint irgendwie so, also du merkst schon, er geht in Richtung Backstory. Der Gegner taucht plötzlich vor dir auf und er sagt so, es ist genau wie damals, als ich in den Fremden landen das erste Mal auf Prinzessin und dann so, nee, ich hab Sonnenwand. Ich bin die Langeweile. Ich fühle echte Langeweile. Also nicht in Charakter, aber ich fühle gerade echte Langeweile. Sag mal, als der Prinz von Carembro mich berief, den Kreuz. Sorry. Warum passiert das immer? Ja, weil ich muss dringend nach Hause, ich muss ins Sanitätszelt gehen, weil ich hab Sonnenbrand. Okay. Hast du nicht mal gesagt, dass man keine Sonnencreme benutzen darf? Genau, ich habe mir bei einem Lab einen extremen Sonnenbrand zugezogen, weil ich einfach in Character nicht an Sonnencreme gedacht habe. Ich habe nicht an Sonnencreme gedacht und dann lagen wir in der Sonne die ganze Zeit, weil natürlich Lab ist auch so der einzige Ort. Wir lagen in der Sonne die ganze Zeit. Moment, ich stelle mir ja vor, eigentlich, aber korrigiere mich, wenn ich dann falsch liege, offensichtlich, dass man kämpfend mit Schwert ineinander reinrennt, Backstory, Backstory, Backstory.
Ja, naja, es gibt halt auch einen Plot und dann gibt es irgendwie einen Mord oder jemand hat jemanden anhand angestiftet, der wurde dann hingerichtet und dann war das wirklich rechtens und bla bla bla. Ja, aber normalerweise ist es ja so, dass bei Lab die ganzen Nerds dann so auch mal aus dem Keller kommen, so ein bisschen klischeehaft gesagt.
Und dann halt auch, bei mir war es ganz krass, einfach überhaupt nicht damit klarkommen, drei Tage im Freien zu sein.
So null, Allergie, Sonnenbrand, Hexenverbrennung ist das alles einfach ein bisschen viel auf einmal und dann legst du einfach am Boden und der Sommer hat ja manchmal so eine, finde ich, also jetzt finde ich ganz passend, ich weiß, was Sommer ist, der Sommer hat ja manchmal so eine Art Fliegenfalligkeit, wo man, wenn man in der Sonne ist, müde wird oder so melancholisch oder so summertime sadness und so. Wenn ich an Sommermusik denke, denke ich auch nicht so an, ey Leute, zieht die Shirts aus, sondern eher summertime. Ich bin so minimal so. Verstehst du, wie ich meine? Naja, es fing sehr ruhig an und dann wurde es Dallas. Irgendwie wird bei mir jeder Song Dallas. Nee, Moment, Dallas.
Bonanza. Bei mir wird jeder Song irgendwann Bonanza. Ich weiss jetzt auch nicht, was da drin ist.
was da drin ist.
Verdammt noch mal, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Aber es ist stark, Bonanza ist stark.
Bonanza ist richtig stark.
Starkes Intro.
Und das ist ja manchmal so, dass wenn du müde bist in der Sonne, legst du dich hin und dann kriegt die Sonne dich richtig, so als wäre das ein Plan.
Man legt sich zu sterben.
Müde zu machen und du legst, du wirst müde und dann ballert die dir einfach die komplette Haut weg einfach so. Die sagt Haut, weg damit. Und dann machst du den hier und gehst. Und die Sonne sagt, nee, kein Spielstopp. Die Sonne erlaubt keinen Spielstopp. Das ist das echte Leben. Genau. Die Sonne schüttelt dich und sagt, wach auf, es ist das echte Leben hier.
Ich hoffe mit deinem Spielen.
Denke ich mir aber auch. Ich denke mir, wenn ich überfallen werden würde, ich würde versuchen so ein, okay, gut, wir sind jetzt laut gerade, aber, also ich denke mir, ich habe manchmal Angst, überfallen zu werden, null Anlass.
Jetzt immer noch im Roleplay oder sind wir jetzt im echten Leben?
Nee, nee, jetzt im echten Leben, aber ich glaube, ich würde das dann ähnlich wie Roleplay machen, so im Sinne von so, okay, kurz OT, ich kann dir mein Geld geben, aber ich gebe dir nicht meinen Geldbeutel mit Führerschein und Ausweis und so.
Aber es ist ein Wettbewerb, das ist ein Wettbewerb, das ist ein Wettbewerb, das ist ein Wettbeplay machen, so im Sinne von so, okay, kurz Ote, ich kann dir mein Geld geben, aber ich gebe dir nicht meinen Geldbeutel mit Führerschein und Ausweis und so. Aber das ist ja Teil des Deals. Nein, nein, nein, pass auf. Aber ich mache die Regel, ich habe das Messer in der Hand. Ich verstehe das, das ist ein gutes Argument. Ich gebe dir gerne, was ich da habe in bar, meine 40 Euro, aber du willst ja nicht meinen Ausweis oder meinen Führerschein. Doch, doch, klar. Gut, aber dann lasse ich mich abstechen. Ja, das denke ich mir auch. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, es ist für mich schlimmer,
neuen Ausweis, Führerschein, Kreditkarte zu beantragen.
Dann stich mich doch bitte einfach ab.
Ja, genau.
Dann sparen wir uns das doch einfach.
Ohne Scheiß ist genau, was ich denke.
Ich denke mir so manchmal, wenn jemand zu mir kommt und so,
und die sind ja auch nervös, das stelle ich mir immer vor.
Ja.
Ich stelle mir vor, die sind, weil jeder kennt das irgendwie,
wenn man jemanden erschrecken will oder sow was. Man ist selber auch ein bisschen nervös. Man ist selber ... Nee, weil man sich versteckt und man will, dass es klappt und so. Und ich stelle mir das vor, das Versteckenspielen in grosser Fallhöhe, grosser Steaks ist ein Verbrechen. Verbrechen, ja. Ein Verbrechen ist quasi ein grosser Prank. Nee, weil die kann man, es kann so viel schief gehen. Es kann Polizeistreife vorbeikommen, es kann, plötzlich kann Batman kommen, plötzlich kann der Typ vor dir Freestyle-Karate machen und haut dir dann so, einfach die in den Kekopp weg oder sowas. Diese Angst sitzt so tief bei dir. Ja, wurde ich mal verprügelt. Andere Geschichte. Findet ihr irgendwie eine Puffepedia oder? So, und ich denke, der ist auch nervös. Und diese Nervosität, also dieses, ich glaube, wovon die dann leben, sind Leute, die sofort einknicken und sagen, ja, hier, habt ihr alles. Aber ich glaube, sobald etwas nicht nach Plan läuft und jemand sagt, das sticht mich ab, ich habe keinen Bock auf einen neuen Personalausweis, die Vorstellung zum Amt zu gehen, hier, nimm die Waffe und erschiesse mich jetzt.
Du nimmst das Messer und erstichst dich selbst selber. Danke, danke, danke, danke. Also wenn mein Ausweis weg ist, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss. Vor allem, man kann nur einen neuen Ausweis mit seinem alten Ausweis. Die Vorstellung, weil mein Reisepass, da bin ich auch immer dabei, wenn der das alles mitnimmt, dann erstich mich gleich hier. Oder ich spring, nee, warte, geh einfach, ich spring kurz einfach selber selber ins Wasser, in Reihen rein. Weil das sehe ich ganz genau so. Und ich glaube aber, dass das wirken würde. Also in meinem Kopf habe ich das schon ein paar Mal durchgespielt, genau dieses Szenario. Und ich glaube, die würden dann auch alles fallen lassen. Da würden die eher sich ein neues Opfer suchen. Glaubst du denn an so Tricks, also so eine zweite Brieftasche, sagt man ja, wenn man irgendwo ist, an einem Urlaubsort, wo man sagt viel Taschendiebe, hol dir eine zweite Brieftasche, tu da wenig Geld rein, dass du das übergeben kannst. Ein Zwanni in den Socken. Dann dieser Gürtel, wo der Gürtel nochmal einen Reisverschluss hat, wo du sogar die Scheine so ganz klein falten musst, was du deinen ersten Tag im Urlaub machst, danach nie wieder, weil du hast keinen Bock, jeden Morgen deinen Gürtel aufzuladen. aufzuladen. In Peru hatte ich noch eine Tasche, so eine ganz flache Geldtasche, so ein Safety-Bag unterm T-Shirt, wo auch noch Geld drin war und ein Ausweis und sowas. Ich habe mir so mit einem Messer so in den Arm geschnitten und dann in unter meiner Haut habe ich die Scheine geschoben, weil ich mir dachte, da guckt er bestimmt nicht nach. Was aber jetzt im Endeffekt dazu führte, dass ich viel mehr Geld an mir trage als normaler. Es wäre nie ein Problem gewesen. Du bist wie so ein Weihnachtsbaum, der überall so kleine Sachen versteckt. Wir sind Adventskalender. Für so einen Kriminellen ist das quasi wie so ein Geschenk. So, jetzt mach die Knarre dann so. So, und jetzt mach die 24 auf. Nein, heute ist doch erst dritter. Mach die 24 auf. Heute ist doch noch nicht Advent. Das geht nicht, das ist viel schlimmer. Und Zwanny. Und zwar nie. Danke. Die ist zwölf jetzt auf.
Mach die zwölf auf.
Ich habe gesagt, mach die zwölf auf.
Fünf Euro.
Fünf Euro, okay.
Und die sechs, das sieht gross aus.
Die sechs auch.
Die sechs, was willst du mit meinem Führerschein?
Dann erschieß es mich.
Nee, komm, dann lassen wir es bis dahin und nicht weiter.
Aber das war in Peru wirklich so, weil ich habe nie Bargeld dabei, nirgendwo, nie.
Wenn ich überfallen werde, können die literally nur mein Handy nehmen und mein Portemonnaie, wo aber kein Geld drin ist, sondern immer nur die Karten.
Heißt, aber in Peru, weil ich dann auch dieses Versteckding extra gekauft habe, habe ich dann immer Bargeld reingepackt.
Was albern ist, weil jetzt, ich wurde zu einem grösseren Ziel, als ich jemals war, durch diese ganzen Safety-Hinweise und da könnt ihr Geld reinpacken, da könnt ihr Geld, wurde ich ganz aufgeregt. Dann habe ich auch in meinen Socken, sollte man auch noch ein bisschen Geld haben, weil die Idee ist quasi, dann, wenn du überfallen wirst, irgendwie fünf Lira oder so dann abzugeben und dann die Leute sozusagen abzulenken damit oder dann sind sie schon zufrieden.
Auch hier würde ich sagen, lass uns ein Abosystem machen. Ich überweise dir jeden Monat zehn Euro und wir sparen uns die ganze Sache. Schutzgeld. Man kriegt dann so eine Karte, die zeigt man dann vor und sagt, ah, du bist Abonnent. Ich glaube, irgendwann ist alles Abonnent, so dass du auch nie wieder Bargeld hast, sondern dass du einfach deine Ausgabenabos genau abstimmst auf deine Einnahmen und exakt genauso viel wie reinkommt, wie da rausgeht,
für irgendwelche Sparpläne, Abos, Kriminalität, Kleidungs-Abo. Alles wird zum Abo.
Alles wird zum Abo.
Auch Kriminalität wird zum Abo.
Genau, und dann wird einfach so viel abgebucht und du hast eine Karte und sagst, ah, Code, wunderbar.
Hierbei die italienische Mafia war schon viel, viel weiter, schon lange.
Und das Spannende finde ich nämlich, kann man, das ist eine Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, kann man die Mafia mit PayPal zahlen zum Beispiel? Ich glaube, das geht. Venmo kannst du rüberschicken. Kann man die Venmoen oder sind sie noch komplett einfach bargeldend? Wir nehmen nur Cash, wir nehmen nur Cash. Apropos, ich habe gerade unser Reddit offen, weil ich da eine sehr lustige Schlagzeile fand, und zwar schreibt unser User Entire Calligrapher, schreibt Stefan hat die Desaströse schon bei Peak in Kloppenburg schon vor Wochen erkannt, Schlagzeile Hamburg, Haustechniker findet Leiche bei Peak in Kloppenburg. Ist ja nicht so lustig, aber schon lustig. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Die haben einfach Gürtel drüber gelegt und dachten, niemand findet die Leiche. Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, also sorry, ich werde nicht bezahlt dafür, die Leichen zu entsorgen. Ja, aber wenn der in der Umkleiderkabine die Hose so eng anzieht, dass er selber sich den Darm zerfetzt, sorry. Klar, die kommen die im Scheiss zu uns, aber es ist auch alles unsere Aufgabe, okay? Entschuldigung, mein Mann ist gerade gestorben. Könnten wir vielleicht da was machen? Haben Sie da noch was, haben Sie ein Lager oder sowas? Behalten Sie die oder wollen Sie die, behalten Sie die oder wollen Sie die? Haben Sie die in einer anderen Grösse vielleicht? Klar, klar, welche Grösse darf es sein? Das ist F. Und ich mache kurz meinen Sticker drauf, okay? Okay. Das machen die nämlich immer. Das denke ich mir immer, wenn die … Sie sind fast pleite, okay? Sie sind fast pleite. Sie sind so kurz davor. Das ist mein Problem, okay? Ich habe schon einen Job. Sie sind so kurz davor. Ja. Mord in der Umkleidekabine. Sticker drauf. Weil die machen immer, auch wenn sie mir nicht helfen, bei der Auswahl von Klamotten, ich will auch nicht, mir soll nicht geholfen werden, ballern die noch ihren Sticker drauf. Da denke ich mir, fein.gen die wahrscheinlich Provisionen für jedes verkaufte Kleidungsstift. Sticker machen auch Spaß, einfach so überall einen Sticker drauf. Ich verstehe es. Auch wenn es dann darum geht, um irgendwie, wie heisst du jetzt, Zwangsvollstrecker, Streckerknecht, Vollstreckungsknecht, Herr mit deinem Geld, der dann überall so Sticker draufklippt, was dir weggenommen wird. Nee, der dann kommt, wenn du zu viel Schulden hast. Der Zwangsmeister. Das ist das Nächste, was wir an einem Henker haben heutzutage. Ich komme, um dein Leben zu ruinieren. Guten Tag, Ding Dong. Hi. Hi, ich bin hier, um ihr Leben zu ruinieren. Viel zu freundlich. Hi. Hi, hallo. Okay. Ich wollte mal sagen, ich bin gekommen, um euer Leben komplett vollends zu ruinieren. Okay, alles klar. Das bisschen, was wir noch haben, werde ich Ihnen jetzt wegnehmen. Alles klar. Wollen Sie es leicht machen, oder kann ich das Abosystem einfach bezahlen? Nein, nein, da würde ich direkt reinkommen. Dip, dip, dip. Und dann hast du so diese Sticker überall. Wofür steht grün? Grün heißt, es geht weg und sehen Sie nie wieder, wird zu einem billigen Ramspreis verkauft. Und blau? Blau heißt, ihr Leben ist komplett in Scherben und wird nie wieder so weit wie früher. Ja, es ist viel blau, es ist viel blau, ein bisschen viel blau. Sie gehören auch mir. Du gehörst jetzt mir. Du gehörst jetzt mir. Du hilfst mir. Wie, ich gehöre jetzt Ihnen so ein bisschen Sklave? Ich bin so ein Leibeigner oder was? Du hilfst mir jetzt. Wie, wohin bei helfen? Ich habe einen Fall. Wir als Zwangsvollstreck haben einen Fall? Ich bin auch noch Detektiv. Ich bin Tierdetektiv. Ich habe tatsächlich hier auf dem Weg hierhin zwei tote Vögel gesehen. Ich auch. Und ich dachte mir, es kann kein Zufall sein. Irgendj ist hier in der Stadt. Meine Theorie, die riesengrosse Glasfassade an unserem riesengroßen gläsernen Gebäude. Was ist das Motiv? Lichteinfall. Also das Motiv ist eher Standortvorteil des Gebäudes. Menschen tun viel wegen Lichteinfall, aber Mord? Ich weiß nicht, so weit würde ich nicht gehen. Also ich glaube einfach, dass die Vögel das nicht sehen und dagegen fliegen.
Lassen Sie ihn. Ich brauche keine Marke, um in dieser Stadt für Gerechtigkeit zu sorgen.
Diesen Vögel wurden Grausames angetan und ich werde sie rächen. Und mir ist das Letzte, was ich tue.
Ich bin vielleicht von der Polizei rausgeflogen, aber die wissen eh nicht, was Gerechtigkeit ist.
Okay, ich dachte, sie sind hier wegen der Leiche, die wir gefunden haben, aber sie kommen jetzt wegen der Vögel … Wegen den beiden Vögel. … die sie auf dem Weg hierher gefunden haben. Ja, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht in diesem Stadt. Okay, aber wir haben eine Leiche bei … Irgendwas … Wir haben eine Leiche hier gefunden, P und C. … nicht zwei Vögel im Park. Wie gesagt, wir haben eine menschliche Leiche. Ja, wahrscheinlich sind die im Fenster geflogen oder … Rattengift gegessen oder so. Ich muss überlegen, was, wer könnte den was, vielleicht eine Katze. Vielleicht eine Katze. Mord aus niedersten tierischen Instinkten. Ja, das passt. Das passt auch zum Leichenbild. Aber können wir kurz mal herausfinden? Also können wir kurz von dem langweiligsten Hörspiel der Welt weggehen? Ich finde die Idee von dem Tierdetektiv gar nicht schlecht.
Ich finde es auch gut.
So der einfach, der versucht, völlig ohne Erfolg das Konzept Mord in der Tierwelt durchzusetzen.
Ja.
Wo Leute sagen, Motiv, ja Hunger.
Ihr wisst ja, ob man Hunger kommt und dann habe ich ihn aufgeregsen.
Aber können wir herausfinden, wer gestorben ist bei P&C?
Wer starb im P&C?
Nein.
Haustechniker findet gleich in Hamburg ein Modehaus. Im Hamburger Modegeschäft ist eine tote Frau in einem Abstellraum entdeckt worden. Offenbar war niemandem der Verwesungsgeruch aufgefallen. Ich glaube, alle dachten, der Geruch hier ist pleite. So riecht Insolvenz. Ja, ja. Man sagt ja immer, dass es nach Pleite riecht. Das ist ja unfassbar. Noch nicht bekannt. Was ist denn los? Erst die in der Rutsche, jetzt bei die Pig und Kloppenburg? Offensichtlich war sie auch nicht vermisst, weil sie ist keine der Polizei bekannte Frau. Niemand hat irgendwie sie vermisst und die konnte noch nicht identifiziert werden. Das ist ja vielleicht eine Einbrecherin, die sich irgendwie die hintenrum einbrechen wollte und dann aber nicht reinkam und dann einfach verhungert ist irgendwo. Ich sag's dir, da geht's drunter und drüber bei Pik und Kloppenburg. Was ist da los? Naja, denen ist alles scheißegal. Die machen bald dicht und jetzt ist so, jetzt geht der Laden vor die Hunde einfach. Aber ich denke mir, ich glaube, die meisten grossen Supermärkte, wenn man die wirklich komplett ausräumen würde, würde man da einige Leichen finden. Wie viele sterben? Ich glaube, einige. Wie viele Menschen sterben im Freizeitplatz? Ich glaube, in jedem handelsüblichen Bällebad findest du zwei Leichen. Wenn die mal komplett einfach ausgebaggert wird, findest du einen ... Hochdruckkärcher. Findest du da Leichen von Vögeln, aber auch von Menschen? Ja, kann sein. Wie viele Menschen glaubst du, sterben in Freizeitparks? Oh, eine Menge. Ja, oder glaubst du nämlich auch? Zuckermatte ist eine Mordwaffe. Zuckermatte ist ne reine Mordwaffe. Und dann glaubst du, sterben die eher auf Achterbahnen oder so, Herzinfarkt oder sowas, oder ist es eher so in der gleisenden Sonne, Herzinfarkt, zu alt, zu jung, zu groß, zu klein, sowas. Sowas gibt viele Gründe für den Tod. Weil ich hab gestern so ein Video geschaut, irgendwie. Zu jung. Er war einfach zu jung. Er war noch zu jung, sagt man ja. Ja, stimmt. Er war doch noch viel zu jung, sagt man häufig. Genau. Weil jetzt ist er gestorben, er war noch viel zu jung. Ja, deswegen denke ich, war das der Grund? Nee, aber ich habe gestern so ein Video gesehen, Haiangriffe, also Leute schwimmen mit Haien. Und dann hieß es, es ist so, so unwahrscheinlich, von einem Hai gebissen zu werden. Irgendwie so eins in whatever, zehn Millionen waren es, glaube ich. Es lagert mich nicht auf die Zahl fest, aber sowas. Es ist wahrscheinlicher, von einem Blitz getroffen zu werden, als von einem Hai gebissen zu werden. Was ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Hai von einem Blitz getroffen wird? Ähnlich gross. Okay. Und jetzt, da meinte einer sogar als lustig, es ist nämlich, und das hat mich komplett, das hat alle Zahlen in Frage stellen lassen, es ist wahrscheinlicher, von einem New Yorker oder einer New Yorkerin gebissen zu werden, als von einem Hai gebissen zu werden. Aber egal, wo du bist, oder was? Jetzt fängt es nämlich an, bei mir zu rattern.
Da habe ich gedacht, so jetzt ist glaube ich nichts mehr.
Und dann vor allem haben die das den Leuten gesagt,
die gleich mit Haien schwimmen.
Die Chance, von einem Hai gebissen zu werden, ist 1 in 10 Millionen.
Ich denke mir, ja gut, für den Erdenbewohner,
für den ganz normalen Durchschnitts-Panierdebewohner
ist die Chance vielleicht 1 zu 10 Millionen. Wenn ich aber mit Haien schwimmen gehe ... Dann steigt das Risiko, das stimmt. Man muss doch die Zahlen anfassen. Leute, es ist ja auch, wenn ich mich ... Wenn du Fallschirm springst, dann kann ich wahrscheinlich eins von 20 Millionen. Ja, weil ich nicht wie nie springe. Ja, weil die absolute Grossteil der Menschheit niemals aus dem Flugzeug springen würde.
Unfassbar.
Du hast völlig recht, ja.
Und dann denke ich mir auch, die Chance, von einem New Yorker gebissen zu werden, ist grösser als von einem Hai gebissen zu werden.
Okay, wenn ich in New York bin ...
Ist sie höher?
Nee, aber ist die Chance so groß?
Eins zu, weiss ich nicht.
Und jetzt ist, glaube ich, die haben einfach die Einwohnerzahl von New York genommen, herausgefunden, ah, die ist niedriger als die Millionenanzahl, die man hat, wenn man vom Hai gebissen werden könnte, eins in zehn Millionen. Und es gibt ja weniger New Yorker als zehn Millionen. Aber die Frage ist halt, wie ist das Beissverhalten der New Yorker? Also, beissen die überdurchschnittlich viel bei, das weisst du ja auch nicht. Ich würde sagen, ja. Also, ich würde auch sagen, ja, dass die mehr beissen andere. Aber man muss sich, das ist eine Stadt, die niemals schläft, das ist, ich spiele noch dazu, Big Apple, Big Bite, Big B, Big Bite. Und dann ist es halt auch so, dass sie sich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen durchbeissen müssen durch die Stadt, also so als figurativ gesprochen. Aber das fand ich total spannend. Wie entstehen Statistiken, und ich glaube nicht, dass die Chance super, super klein ist, von einem Haig gebissen zu werden, weil dann waren auch Leute dabei, die halt die ganze Zeit mit Haien schwimmen. Das ist deren Beruf. Also die Chance, von einem Stachelrochen ins Herz gestochen zu werden, wie Steve Irvin gestorben ist, ist wahrscheinlich eins zu zweihundert Milliarden oder sowas. Am Ende ist es der Stachelrochen. Aber wenn dein Job ist,
literally Stachelrochen aufzuscheuchen
für die Kamera,
ist es wahrscheinlich höher.
Eins zu zwei oder so.
Wenn dein Job ist,
Krokodile so wütend zu machen
und dich mit denen im Schlamm zu rollen,
dann hast du noch mal eine andere
Wahrscheinlichkeit als jeder
andere Mensch der Welt. Jemand, der in Bottrop ist, wo es einfach keine Krokodile gibt. Zwei vielleicht. Ich wrestle mit Bären. Naja, keine Angst. Die Chance, von einem Bären getötet zu werden, ist 1 zu 160 Millionen. Okay, weil ich wrestle, das ist mein Hauptberuf, ich bin Bärenwrestler. Du müsstest 160 Millionen Bären wrestlen, um einmal getötet zu werden, und so viele Bären gibt es gar nicht. Also es ist quasi absolut ... Nur um mir vielleicht ihre Mathematik ein bisschen anzufassen. Mein Hauptberuf ist es, ich ringe mit Bären. Also ich rangel mit denen. Das ist ihr Beruf? Ja, genau. Ich kriege Geld dafür. Von wem? Von Sponsoren. Okay, interessant. Bären eher feindlich gesinnten Sponsoren. Deswegen dieses Peak-Kloppenburg-T-Shirt. Genau, Peak-Kloppenburg. Ja, die investieren immer gut. Ich ringe mit Bären. Dann boxen wir uns, man wirft sich auf den Boden und so. Und es geht halt, weil Kollegen, alle Kollegen sind tot, weil, deswegen verstehe ich nicht, wie das... Das verringert die Wahrscheinlichkeit ja noch mal. Was denen passiert ist?
Was denen passiert ist, ja, ja.
Moment, wenn an einem Roulett-Tisch jemand rot hat, verhindert das meine Wahrscheinlichkeit, rot zu bekommen? Genau so ist es, ja. Ich glaube, alles ist falsch. Ich glaube, wir müssen alle noch mal nachrechnen. Hol doch mal die Taschenrechner raus. Ich glaube Statistiken nicht mehr. Es ist schwierig. Vor allem dann auch so die Chance, von einem Blitz getroffen zu werden,
ist ja höher,
wenn ich jemand bin, der
von der Persönlichkeit heraus eher,
wenn es gewittert, ziemlich raus
gehe, auf offene Felder. Ja, man müsste eigentlich
sagen, wie viele Leute werden
von Blitz getroffen, von den Leuten,
die bei Gewitter draußen sind,
in der Nähe eines Baumes,
und dann kannst du eine vernünftige Wahrscheinlichkeit machen. Aber ich sag mal, dieses ganze Haiding, ab welchem Punkt kommt die Haie-PR und sagt, Leute, wir sind schon gefährlich, weil wir ständig hören, 1 zu 160 Millionen, wir sind schon immer noch die fucking grössten Raubtiere der Welt, die euch locker zerfleischen können. Okay, beiss mich, beiss mich.
Naja, nein, aber jetzt die wahrscheinlich...
Okay, beiss mich. Ne, beiss mich einfach jetzt.
Also, ohne Scheiss. Das ist ja Quatsch, ich will jetzt
nicht... Nein, ich wollte einfach nur sagen, dass wir
schon... Also wir sind schon...
Hier, arm. Ja, okay, also wenn du es so
drauf anlegst, ich meine,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer noch relativ gering, dass ich dich
beissen würde. Wirklich? Extrem gering.
Wie lame. Naja, wir... Heisen ich dich beißen würde. Wirklich? Extrem gering. Wie lame.
Haie sind lame. Du bist lame.
Wir sind nicht lame.
Deswegen bin ich kom.
Haie sind nicht lame.
Wir sind gefährlich. Fürchtet uns.
Okay?
Es sterben mehr Leute durch Haushaltsunfällen als durch Haiangriffe. Ja.
Also mehr Leute sterben irgendwie, weil sie, keine Ahnung, Priel trinken. Jungs, Jungs, wir müssen nie zahlen. Jungs zusammenrotzen. Wir brauchen mal, wir brauchen mal. Zusammenrotzen. Kann doch nicht sein, dass uns ein kleines Plösschen. Kann doch nicht sein, dass uns Priel besiegt. Leute, Priel? Wir wurden letztes Jahr von Looping Louis überholt. Looping Louis! Wie soll das passieren? Ja, wie soll das passieren? Wir haben riesige Zähne und es sterben mehr Leute durch fucking Looping Louis. Wie stirbt man bei Looping Louis? Ja, das frage ich mich auch! Also eine kleine Flössel wird hochgehoben. Entschuldigung. Ja, Gustav. Wie stirbt man an Looping Louis? Also nur um es zu verstehen. Also ich will es nicht, ich will es nur verstehen. Anscheinend kann man, wenn man den Kopf zu niedrig macht und Looping Louis mit einer relativ hohen Geschwindigkeit einem in den Mund fliegt, dann hat es eine gewisse Verschluckungsgefahr. Okay, okay, okay. Ähm, gut, Brainstorming, einfach mal kurz, dass wir cooler werden. Also was können wir machen, damit wir cooler wirken? Ja, wir müssen die Zahlen hochkriegen, eins in 160 Millionen ist einfach zu schlecht. Okay, ich habe ein Shirt gemacht. Gut. Hier, Haie töten Menschen.
Sehr gut.
Genau, also vorne ist das Haiesymbol drauf und so und halt, ähm, dann eine andere Idee hatte ich noch. Jaws, Jaws 2, 3, ja, 4, eine Fortsetzung von Jaws. Ich meine, ich bin ein Hai und selbst ich habe nicht alle Teile gesehen. Also irgendwo steigt man auch aus.
Eine Fortsetzung des Jaws-Franchises?
Sehr gut.
Weil ja, damals, als es herauskam, Leute, das war unser Peak.
Da waren wir im coolsten, da waren wir im gefährlichsten.
Da hieß es, Haie sind scary, ich gehe nicht mehr ins Wasser.
Jetzt gehen sehr viele Leute ins Wasser.
Es sind mehr Leute, für mich zu viele Leute im Wasser.
Ja, oder wir machen Looping Louis sicherer.
Ah! Also, dass wir da gucken. Es wird auf Korallen gehauen. Das ist da probieren. Es wird auf Korallen gehauen, ja, sehr gut. Looping Louis sicherer. Einfach so einen großen, so ein Schaumstoffding in die Mitte draufsetzen. Es passt genau unten Looping Louis rein. Was ist das tödlichste Brettspiel? Definitiv. Jenga, oder? Nee, Ligretto. Libretto? Das spielt Stefan mit seinen adligen Freunden, dann wird erstmal ein schöner Rosé aufgemacht. Jesus Christ. Was ist das denn? Kinder, reden wir auf fucking Ligretto. Ja, das adlige Spiel Ligretto. Einfach so ein Kartenablegespiel mit der kindlichsten Kinderschrift drauf. Nie gehört Ligretto? Das ist einfach so ein Ablegespiel, alle haben Karten, dann musst du halt schnell reagieren, wenn ein Startbild und deine Zahl ablegbar ist, machst du es drauf. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Running Gag in unserem Freundeskreis gewesen, man legt halt sehr aggressiv auf, weil es ist halt einfach so ein Tsch, Tsch, und alle schlagen sich auf Karten und man ist so kurz davor, einfach so den Gegner, also Slash-Freund, mit dem man da abends verbringt, einfach so zu nehmen und einfach so auf den Tisch zu ...
Auf jeden Fall. Ich kenne das von Halligalli, wo du auf diese Glocke ...
Halligalli.
Und da wirklich, boah, ich kann mir da nicht dran denken, weil wirklich, ich habe Halligalli gespielt und wollte zwei auf diese Glocke hauen und dann haben sich die Finger genau so getroffen, dass der eine seinen Fingernagel unter den Fingernagel des anderen geschoben hat, weil die einfach wirklich zack mit einer hohen Geschwindigkeit und da haben wir wirklich gesagt, Leute, das kann man nicht. Stop it. Spielstopp. Vor allem, dass einfach zu viel Kraftstöße aufeinander. Die Labgeste gemacht. Ja genau, raus, raus, raus, raus. Oh Gott, oh Gott, das ist ja unangenehm. Es ist wirklich so unangenehm und seitdem kann ich nicht mehr heiligallig spielen. Ich habe das oft gespielt, immer in der Zivi-Zeit mit Kindern, weil Kinder einfach nicht fucking zählen können. Es ist so leicht. Vor allem, es ist wirklich so dumm. Das Bild, was sich von dir zeichnet in deiner Zivi-Zeit, ist immer unsympathischer. Du hast gesagt, du solltest mit denen schwimmen gehen. Und dann hast du erzählt, wie du die ganze Zeit vom Zehner gesprungen bist und denen die Kinder egal waren. Und du hast literally gesagt, ja, bei denen, die gut schwimmen müssen, ist egal, die überschätzen sich vielleicht. Und die einzigen, die so mittelgut schwimmen, sind das Problem. Ich hatte oft zu viel Spaß an den Sachen, die die Kinder machen sollten. Und jetzt klang es gerade eher so, aber korrigere mich, wenn ich falsch liege, dass Halligalli war ein Spiel, was gut war für dich, weil du gewinnen konntest, weil die nicht zählen können. Die haben so schwache Hände, du kannst teilweise wirklich die Hand weghauen, die auf dem Weg zur Glocke ist, die haben keine Chance. Aber ich habe auch einen. Herr Will, genau, und zwar, also der Felix kam nach Hause und. Meinen Sie Felix, der gewonnen hat bei Halligalli oder der, der verloren hat bei Halligalli? Er hat wohl verloren, hat er erzählt. Darum geht es aber gar nicht. Aber er hat sehr viele blaue Flecken an seinem Arm und mehrere Fingernägel sind abgetrennt worden. Deswegen ist die Frage, also er hat gesagt, bei Cloedo hätten sie Gewalt angewendet, damit sie heraus, schneller herausfinden. Es war ein Verhör, es war ein Verhör. Es war ein Verhör und durchaus intensive Verhörtechnologie. Ich will jetzt nicht Waterboarding sagen. Moderne Verhörmethoden. Aber sie haben Wasser, also sie haben ihn nicht schlafen lassen, über den Mittagsschlaf haben sie geskippt und haben ihn stattdessen mit Wassertropfen wachgehalten. Er wusste, wer der Mörder war. Er hatte genauso viele Hinweise wie sie. Was würden Sie tun, wenn Sie wissen, da ist jemand, der weiß, wer der Mörder ist? Aber wo er... Wer wird als nächstes ermordet? Ich muss das aufhalten. Ganz kurz, es ist ja ein Brettspiel, es soll die Kinder ja mehr Spaß haben als sie, als Erzieher und so. Und jetzt haben die Leute angefangen, Preuzverhör in kalte Räume zu setzen. Warum darf ich denn keinen Spaß haben an Spielen? Wie darf ich denn Spaß haben? Wie darf ich denn Spaß haben? Klar. Dafür bin ich hier. Ja, nee, eher die Kinder sind eher hier, damit sie Spaß haben erzogen werden, so ein bisschen und so. Das ist eher eigentlich für mich. Für Sie? Für mich. Ich habe diesen Kindergarten komplett alleine aufgebaut, um selber Spaß zu haben. Warum wollen Sie Spaß haben bei der Kindererziehung? Es schliesst sich mir jetzt nicht so genau. Es ist ja irgendwie ihr Job und so und die Kinder werden verlässt. Also, man hört nie auf, Kind zu sein. Nur bei dem Kindergarten verlassen heißt es nicht, dass der Kindergarten uns verlässt. Aber man sollte vielleicht aufhören, Kind zu sein. Nur bei dem Kindergarten verlassen heißt es nicht, dass der Kindergarten uns verlässt. Aber man sollte vielleicht aufhören, Kind zu sein, wenn man im Kindergarten... Wirklich? Jetzt, wo ich ganz oben bin? Jetzt, wo ich auf der Rangliste ganz oben bin? In Cluedo, Halligalli und Hasen und Kohl? Ich glaube, Felix lasse ich nicht mehr in diesen Kindergarten. Also besser ist es. So ein Halligalliefersager. Nur bei Verstecken bin ich noch nicht der Beste. Bei Verstecken haben Kinder einen Vorteil. Weil sie klein sind. Weil die so klein sind, ne? Weil sie winzig klein sind. Sich überall reinschieben können. In jede noch so kleine Ritze. Hör ich da einen Schrei? Hör ich da einen Schrei aus einem abgesperrten Raum? Moment mal, das ist Agathe. Hat sich wahrscheinlich zu gut versteckt beim Versteckenspielen. Ja, wenn wir hier den Kindergarten ausräumen, finden wir wahrscheinlich Leichen. Zu gut versteckt. Sie sind lustiger, Kerl. Ich lasse den Felix bei. Ach, danke schön. Ach Gott, aber genau so stell ich mir vor, du, das, was Florentin ist, will Spaß haben.
Aber ich habe irgendwann, gab es ein Kind, das war immer ganz schlecht bei Halligalli, und dann habe ich gesagt, ich coach dich jetzt. Bootcamp. Habe ich gesagt, so jetzt wird gecoacht. Und dann gab es so eine Rocky-artige Montage. So mit den Früchten, mit den Bananen, weil du musst ja immer hauen, wenn du fünf hast.
Und dann habe ich immer schon gesagt, der Trick von Halligalli ist super leicht, weil du musst ja die Karte legen und wenn dann fünf von der gleichen Sorte sind, dann muss man hauen. Genau. Und was die Kinder immer falsch machen ist, da wird eine Karte gelegt und dann fangen die erst an zu rechnen. Ich sage aber nein, wenn da vier Bananen sind, denk, aber wenn da jetzt eine Banane kommt, dann haue ich drauf. Und allein mit diesem Trick hat er alle anderen fertig gemacht. Kinder, die drei Jahre älter waren als er, hat er fertig gemacht. Weil du im Bootcamp da standest, mit so einer kurzen Hose und so einer Stoppuhr. Genau. Und dann hast du den so, und dann immer so, oh go, und dann musste er immer die Reaktionsnets. Drei Erdbeeren liegen schon, was brauchst du noch? Zwei. Vier Erdbeeren liegen schon, was brauchst du noch? Eine Banane liegt da schon, was brauchst du noch? Sehr gut, richtig. So werden wir es ganz nach oben machen, nach Monaco zur Halligalli-Meisterschaft.
Ich will nicht, sie wollen nach Monaco. Ich will nicht nach Monaco zur Halligalli-Meisterschaft. Ich will nur meinen Erdbeer-Drink und meine Vanillemilch. Du kannst das schaffen, was ich nie konnte.
Was ich nie konnte.
Damals hätte ich die Chance gehabt, nach Monaco zu fahren, aber dann wurde eine Leiche in meinem Kindergarten gefunden.
Und du kannst jetzt das tun, was ich nie konnte. Damals hätte ich die Chance gehabt, nach Monaco zu fahren, aber dann wurde eine Leiche
in meinem Kindergarten gefunden.
Und du kannst jetzt das tun, was ich nie konnte.
Warum ist die Meisterschaft von Halligalli
überhaupt in Monaco? Ich dachte, das wäre so ein deutsches
Spiel, so Ravensburger oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nur die Reichen und Adligen
spielen.
Okay, einmal nach Monaco
zur Halligalli-Weltmeisterschaft.
Und dann war es das, wenn ich raus, okay?
Dann müssen sie mich gehen lassen.
Dann müsst ihr raus.
Okay.
Ich glaube, man könnte einen guten Halligalli-Film machen, oder?
Also Rocky.
Ich glaube, das ist so Rocky, Halli-Halli-Rocki.
Halli-Rocki und dann wirklich besteht zu 99 Prozent aus Zeitlupenaufnahmen,
wie Hände aufeinander gehen und dann auch immer so ganz knapp aneinander vorbei und der Zuschauer denkt sich so, fast hätten sie sich getroffen. Und dann ding! Und der Film hört nicht auf, das weniger spannend zu finden. Also er hört nicht auf, das geil zu finden. Du merkst im Film an, dass er das sehr zu oft macht. Also du hast am Anfang, das Opening ist schon dieses Hände, dieses Slow-Mo aufeinander klatschen. Und dann so, wenn Haut auf Haut kommt und es so ein bisschen so wabert, wie so ein Epizentrum. Genau. Aber der Film hört nicht auf, eine mega coole Idee zu finden. Ich finde das lustig, weil manchmal ist das so, man sieht dann den Regisseur im Schnittraum sagen, nee, nee, ist nochmal geil, ist nochmal genauso geil. Ja, aber Herr Nolan, wir haben das jetzt schon sechsmal gemacht und wir sind bei der Hälfte des Films. Nochmal. Nochmal. Hände in Zeitlupe. Aufeinander hauen. Hände in Zeitlupe. Das ganze Finale ist 30 Minuten lang Hände, die aufeinander hauen. Noch vierzig draus. Noch langsamer. Herr Nolan, sicher, dass Sie sollten Ihren Job lassen. Sie sind fertig. Oppenheimer schon gesehen? Nee, gibt es den schon? Nein, ich glaube nicht in Deutschland. Ach so, warum nicht? Wegen... Nee, ich glaube, es gibt den noch nicht in Deutschland. Es gibt den bald in Deutschland, aber jetzt noch nicht. Oppenheimer ist auch so ein geiler Name einfach. Oppenheimer. Oppen. Was bist du eigentlich für Oppenheimer? Oppenheimer, ja. Das klingt wie ein Pappenheimer. Fantastisch. Aber das wäre ein guter Parodie-Film. Pappenheimer? Eigentlich gar nicht schlecht. Genau so ernst. Von einem anderen Physiker, der einfach so die Spaltung einfach nicht gecheckt hat. Hä? Aber warum, also warum? Der Kern ist doch der Kern. Wie kann der gespalten werden? P, oder ist er so der Joker, also der lustige Prankster aus dem Büro. Ja. So, und auch der Physiker. Und er ist aber so, der macht dann so, weiß ich nicht, Cola in den Kaffeebecher oder so. Ja, genau. Aber so Dinge, die niemandem wehtun, aber jetzt macht er die Prankster. Ja. Aber genauso ernst erzählt, weil er breit das auch ernst vor. Das finde ich auch immer eine interessante Figur für Filme. So das Genie, das aber super nervig ist so. So wie Mozart zum Beispiel in den Mozart-Filmen. Der ist immer viel zu albern und viel zu fröhlich für diese ernsten Anlässe, aber er ist halt einfach der Beste. Und so eine Art von Figur finde ich eigentlich perfekt mit Pappenheimer, der einfach der krasseste Physiker ist und dann so auch beim Nobelpreis hat er so eine Schockhand, so einen Handschlag und so ein Schocker drin und so.
Pappen, sie sind wenig Pappenheimer. Und dann geht er so ins Mikrofon und sagt,
das, das, das, und alles so, sorry, und er so, das, und einfach viel zu lang und das Mikro ist an, wir sehen es. Ja, ja, kein Wackelkontakt. Pappenheimer. Pappenheimer? Pappenheimer finde ich super. Finde ich richtig gut. Pappenheimer. Jetzt haben wir keine Sketchshow, halt leider mehr. Ja, nein. Deswegen bitte. Guido, Kanz, wir brauchen dich. Hör auf, hör auf. Falls ihr da draußen eine Sketchshow habt. Inflationär. Lass uns doch einfach jetzt sagen, Circus Halligalli gibt es, nein, Late Night Berlin kann Pappenheimer haben, oder gibt es auch andere Late Night Shows in Deutschland? Ich glaube, gar nicht mehr. Ja. Du musst mal eine machen. Du musst mal so eine Eric-Andre-artige Show machen. Mit Pappenheimer. Und dann könnte man jetzt eigentlich easy so ein Sketch raushauen. Finde ich super gut. Ja, dann gibt es halt wieder Snacks, ne? Das war halt schon immer gut, dass du halt immer den Snackbären hattest. Wir können auch einfach hier Snacks kaufen. Nein, es gibt ja hier tatsächlich auch einen Snackartigen Snackbären, aber ich war das so... Das ist so lustig. Es gibt hier eine Küche in der Nähe und da ist so eine Gemeinschaftsküche und da gibt es auch so einen Snackbär und dann bin ich dahin und dachte mir,, was gibt es denn da und dann ist dieses Snackbear wirklich von links bis recht dicht gedrängt, gedrückt, gefüllt, nur mit Twix. Nur Twix! Aber wirklich, also wirklich in drei Reihen übereinander, dicht an dicht, nur Twix! Also wer auch immer diesen Snackbären, wo man selber kaufen kann, kann man dann Münze reinwerfen und sich was nehmen auf Vertrauensbasis, hat gesagt, was gibt's für gute Riegel. Aber wenn sie Vertrauensbasis immer so sagen, dann verliert das Geschäftsmodell einen Wert. Genau. Vertrauensbasis. Ja, also sie nehmen sich einen Twix raus und dann tun sie da Geld rein auf Vertrauensbasis. Aber apropos Vertrauensbau, das ganz kurz mal eben, weil das habe ich neulich gedacht, Flughäfen, ne? Ja. Null Vertrauensbasis. Es ist wichtig, du wirst durchleuchtet, Nacktscanner, alles ist auf Sicherheit aus. Skeptische Blicke. Alles skeptische Blicke, wahnsinnig sicher, lassen Sie den Koffer nicht unbeaufsichtig stehen. Ja. Herzlich willkommen in Bonn, Köln, Bonn. Ja. Wie die Stimme macht aber das ist die alte Stimme von Pierce Brosnan, das bin ich immer wahnsinnig lustig. Und soll man nicht unbeaufsichtig stehen lassen, weil sonst wird es literally gesprengt. Also es wird nicht gar nicht, nur in Vertrauensbasis, sehr viel Skepsis, ausser, wenn man aus dem Flieger kommt und sich an diese Baggage-Belts ständ, diese Gepäck-Ausgabe. Rein vertrauensbasierte Ausgabe. Das ist so unglaublich. Du kannst dich einfach hinstellen und jeden einzelnen Koffer nehmen. Aber es heißt also, zu mir hat man noch gesagt, wenn du aus dem Auto aussteigst, nimm alle Sachen mit, lass nichts im Auto drin, im abgeschlossenen Auto, weil es könnte jemand einbrechen und das klauen. Aber es ist völlig normal, seine ganzen Wertsachen in einen Koffer zu packen, in den Urlaub zu fliegen und dann mit allen anderen Menschen an dieser Gepäckausgabe zu warten. Und niemand hat da jemals ... Ich kenne auch niemanden, von dem was geklaut wurde. Es ist mal nicht mitgekommen. Ja, die Frage ist, würdest du aufgehalten werden, wenn du dann so vier Koffer hast und so mit vier Koffern rausgehst und einfach so ... Nee, es würden den Leuten helfen. Ah, okay, passt. Wie schnell das du ich, ist fertig.
Der hat viel zu tragen.
Ich helfe ihm jetzt, das noch draufzutragen.
Können Sie mir den Koffer auch noch geben?
Das stimmt.
Es ist so irre.
Es ist wirklich das einzige Mal, wo man sich in der Gesellschaft
darauf geeinigt hat, dass das nicht thematisiert wird.
Vor allem, du kannst ja, wenn du erwischt wirst, einfach sagen,
ah, okay, sorry, meiner sieht so ähnlich aus.
Genau.
Es gibt null Fallhöhen.
Niemand wird sagen, schnell, tackle den weg, Taser.
Es wird schon häufig mein Koffer genommen.
Ja.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, ah, sorry, ist meiner.
Vielen Dank. Genau. Es gibt null Fallhöhe, niemand würde sagen, schnell, tackle den weg, taser. Es wird schon häufig mein Koffer genommen, und dann habe ich gesagt, ah, sorry, ist meiner, und dann hat der oder diejenige gesagt, ah, ja, sorry, nicht gesehen, ich habe so einen ähnlichen. Und ich war nicht sauer, ich habe gesagt, ah, danke schön, das haben sie schon runtergeholt. Und dann geht man damit weg. Wie dumm die Leute auch sind, oder? Nehmen einfach irgendwas und dann natürlich auch wieder so, was entsteht für eine Situation, die Koffer sind verwechselt, du hast dann die Drogenkurier-Koffer und musst in anderen Stimmen sein Soberschreit. Ihr macht das schon. Aber geil wäre neu, Sat.1 Filmfilm, ihr macht das schon. Ihr versteht schon, was wir meinen. Aber ich find's gut, zum Beispiel, also ich nehme, eine Frau nimmt meinen Koffer und ich geh zu ihr hin und sag, jetzt habe ich jetzt meine Tim eingenommen und sie sagt, Entschuldigung, meine sie zu Elia.
Und man sagt, danke schön, keine Skepsis angebracht und fällt mit dem weg und dann sieht man sie, wie sie einen pinken Koffer nimmt und dann so wegfährt. So aussieht wie so ein Burger. Genau, das ist ihr Koffer, ihr pinker Burger Koffer. Und man denkt, sie wollte den, dann würde ich sagen, sie wollte den gerade klauen, sie wollte gerade meinen Koffer klauen. Wirst du dann auch zu ihr hingehen und sagen, das sieht ja gar nicht so aus wie mein Koffer. Ach so, ach nee, Entschuldigung, Burger ähnlich. Naja, ich finde, der hat schon, der Griff ist ähnlich. Ja, okay, naja, ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen Tag. Okay. Ich finde das so lustig. Das ist der eine Raum, ich wünschte mir eine Gesellschaft, wo alles so ist wie diesem Raum. Man lässt Fahrräder draußen stehen, es wird nichts geklaut. Ich glaube, der Grund, warum das da so ist, ist, man ist dieser eingeschweißte Haufen. Man ist zusammen geflogen, man hat zusammen die Gravitation besiegt. Erfolgreich, in den meisten Fällen. Na gut, nicht ganz erfolgreich, man ist wieder auf dem Boden der Teilnahme zurückgekommen. Es ist quasi Lost in Klein. Bei Lost landen sie auf einer Insel und müssen sich zusammen durchschlagen. Und hier ist man halt am Flughafen gelandet. Man muss sich aber trotzdem zusammen durchschlagen. Es ist einfach diese Schicksalsgemeinschaft, die hier zusammengekommen ist, wo man sich einfach vertraut. Wo man einfach weiß, Gesundheit Einfach weiss, ich habe jetzt ihr Kind achteinhalb Stunden lang schreien hören.
Wir sind irgendwie die Brüder, wir sind zusammengewachsen.
Ja, super, finde ich gut. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Erklärung.
Man ist zusammen durch die Hölle gegangen, die schreckliches Airline-Food grauenvolle Filme,
die man nicht gehört hat, weil die Motoren lauter sind als diese kleinen Lautsprecher.
Ja, vor allem man liebt ja Filme, in denen Flugzeuge abstürzen, die leider da nicht gezeigt werden. Genau, alle sind sauer, weil sie keine Flugzeugeabstürze gucken konnten für anderthalb Stunden. Mann, es ist ja dieses psychologische Ding, dass wenn jemand sagt, Entschuldigung, wir haben jetzt alle Filme rausgenommen, in denen Flugzeuge abstürzen. Und genau in dem, wenn du denkst, ich würde jetzt so, so gerne Filme anbauen. Überhaupt, alle Filme, die mir jetzt einzahlen, die sich gerne gucken würde, haben alle Flugzeugabflüsse drin, weil das wie dein Gehirn funktioniert. Speed 3, wo sie in einem Flugzeug sind, das nicht langsamer werden darf? Drückt auf! Drückt auf auf die Tube! Jetzt hat Hollywood wirklich keine Ideen mehr. Lass uns das Ganze in einen Bereich legen, wo es gar kein Problem ist. Und Flugzeuge müssen auch normalerweise immer eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit haben, sondern stürzen sie ab.
Das ist die Idee, ist nicht wie ein Auto.
Ja, okay, dann schreiben Sie doch selber die Ideen.
Ja, okay, dann schreibe ich selber die Ideen.
Ja, Sie sind der FedEx-Typ, der hier, also ich meine.
Ja, bessere Ideen als das habe ich auch noch.
Ja, okay, bitte. Zwar ein Krokodil wird
geflogen von A nach B in ein Zoo
und das Krokodil übernimmt dann das Flugzeug.
So. Aber die Geschwindigkeit darf
auch nicht unterschritten werden.
Ja.
Vielleicht häng ich zu sehr an dieser Einigung.
Ja, kill your darlings.
Einfach lass die Geschwindigkeit einfach raus.
Das ist sehr abstrakt für den Zuschauer.
Okay.
Und dann so ein Typen nebenan die Kette durchgeschnitten.
Your my darling.
Und er so, oh, danke schön.
Und stirbt.
Aber du weißt, was sie sagen, Schatz.
Kill your darlings. Oh, nice, so ein Metafilm, so ein Metafilm über Filmtropen, wo er am Ende seine Frau umbringt, weil sie zu viel Platz eingenommen hat in dem Film, man muss zu kürzen. Okay, weil ihre B-Story, Kill Your Darlings, schwierig zu verstehen jetzt natürlich, wäre Meter und auch nicht mehr so lustig, ehrlich gesagt,zen. Okay. Ihre B-Story. Kill Your Darlings, schwierig zu verstehen jetzt, wäre Meter und auch nicht mehr so lustig, ehrlich gesagt. Aber warum nicht, es gibt ja jetzt auf Netflix so einen Film über Filmklischees, den fand ich gut. Krieg ich nicht. Hab ich nicht gesehen. Muss ja auch nicht sein. Muss ja auch nicht sein. Ist ja auch in Ordnung, Stefan. Es ist immer schwer, mit dir über Filme zu reden, die du nicht gesehen hast. Bist du jetzt traurig? Ja, weil jetzt hast du wieder einen Film mehr gesehen, als ich gesehen habe. Jetzt musst du wieder zwei nachholen. Alles auf die falsche Karte gesetzt. Kennst du das nicht, wenn man abends zu einem Freundeskreis geht und so, dann habt ihr jetzt auch Succession angefangen? Und damals habe ich noch keine Succession geguckt. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, ich habe alles auf Beef gesetzt. Ich habe alles auf die falsche Serie gesetzt wieder. Ich habe den ganzen Tag Nachrichten geschaut, weil ich dachte, wir diskutieren über Tagesaktuelles und jetzt reden die nur über Succession. Und da versucht man immer so ungelenkt das Gespräch dahin zu bringen, dass man wieder mitreden kann. Aber Ligretto ist schon ein tolles Kartenspiel. Hm, was? Hm, was? Hä? Hä? Hä? Was hast du gerade gesagt? Hä, was? Hä? Was kam gerade aus deinem dreckigen Mund? Was hast du gesagt? Hast du gerade irgendwas gesagt, was mit Succession zu tun hat oder was nicht damit zu tun hat? Nichts, nein. Alle reden auch so angepisst wie bei Succession. Tolle Serie, jetzt beendet worden. Ja, ich bin ja jetzt wieder, also ich probiere jetzt, ist immer so ein bisschen diese Postserienlehlehre und jetzt habe ich versucht mit der Tour de France Doku anzufangen, nach der Drive to Survive Formel 1 Doku Serie auf Netflix jetzt, Au coeur de peleton, ein ähnlich schmissiger Name für die Tour de France Serie. Genau. Und ich kann das nicht angucken, die tun mir so leid. Die müssen sich so anstrengen, die Arme, mit ihr auf ihren Fahrrädern und dann fallen die ständig hin und das tut mir so leid. Du kommst aber auch vom falschen Sport gerade. Ich komme vom falschen Sport, wo du so ein Auto liegst, wo die quasi gar nichts machen müssen, halt so ein bisschen. Und dann, was ich auch finde, die kriegen dann immer so Essen gereicht, während sie Fahrrad fahren. Und dann fährt er mit dem Fahrrad und dann fährt neben denen so ein Auto und er sagt, hier, was willst du essen? Kohlenhydrate oder Protein oder und der sagt so, keine Ahnung, ich fahr gerade rennen, du Vollidiot. Schatz, Schatz, was willst du essen? Ich hab Muffins, ich hab Muffins oder ein Butterbrot. Nee, ich fahr gerade rennen. Ich fahr gerade, was ist denn? Ich fahr gerade, Mama, sie hat gesagt, ich brauch nichts. Und dann nehmen die irgend so dieses Kohlenhydrate, Essen oder Schleim oder was auch immer und dann drücken die sich das in den Mund und werfen den Müll auf den Boden. Und ich sag dann, wie kann man denn den Sport anschauen, wenn die einfach den Müll auf den Boden werfen? Steck das doch ein oder mach dann den Mülleimer alle zehn Meter oder so. Aber da hat mich der Sport schon komplett verlor. Oder mach so einen Biathlon-artigen Sport draus, dass du dann das, was du gegessen hast, du stellst da so kleine Ziele auf. Sehr gut, so wie ein Basketballkorb. Und du kriegst quasi Sekunden geschenkt am Ende auf die Rennzeit, wenn du das auch noch, wenn du es schaffst, wegzuwerfen, wenn du Recycling bin. Mega gut, finde ich richtig gut. Aber mir ist es zu anstrengend. Also ich denke mir bei der Tour de France immer, Leute, entspannt euch ein bisschen. Wenn alle langsamer fahren, mal einmal eine Pause, müssen wir alle weniger trainieren. Ja, einfach einmal eine Pause. Müssen sich nur alle dran halten. Wenn wir alle nicht besser, ganz kurz, Leute, Leute, stopp, stopp, hey, Henry, stopp. Ja, sorry. Wenn wir alle bisschen weniger Gas geben. Okay, weiter. Ne, fahren wir das gleiche Rennen, aber mit weniger Energie. Wir verbrauchen weniger Energie. Ist weniger anstrengend. Okay. Wenn wir uns alle einigen, dass niemand ausbricht, wir alle gemeinsam weniger trainieren im Jahr. Also jeder macht ungefähr 50 Prozent. Von dem, was wir gerade können. Aber genau 50 Prozent, nicht mehr. Genau, die anderen haben immer noch genauso das gleiche spannende, wenn alle mitdenken, versteht ihr überhaupt, haben alle genau das gleiche spannende Rennen, gucken sie ja, nur halt auf 50%iger Geschwindigkeit. Stefane, hör zu. Ich komme seit 200 Jahren aus einer Dynastie von Fahrradfahrern. Ich muss dieses Rennen gewinnen, koste es was es wolle. Ich habe mein ganzes Leben lang trainiert. Ich werfe Müll auf die Strasse, ich interessiere mich nicht dafür. Ich werfe Dinge einfach auf die Strasse, es ist mir egal. Schon mein ganzes Leben lang. Mein Vater hat es auch so gemacht und ich werde es auch wieder so machen. Wenn ich etwas esse, eine schöne Madeleine auf der Strasse oder ein Baguette, ich werfe es auf die Strasse. Ich werfe auf die Strasse, es ist mir egal, weil ich bin ein Tour de France Fahrer. Wir haben gerade etwas anderes gesprochen. Tour de France Fahrer. Und wenn Sie sagen wollen, ich darf nicht mehr auf die Strasse werfen, sage ich, mein Vater hat auf die Strasse geworfen. Mein Grossvater hat auf die Strasse geworfen. Wir haben alles unsere Baguette Papier... Fahrern wir jetzt an den Nennen oder nicht? Alles auf die... Fahrern wir jetzt an den Nennen oder nicht? So, ich will den Fahrern in Nennen. Immer kommt der Tag, wo wir das alles rausschneiden müssen, aber heute noch nicht. Nee, das ist es nämlich genau noch. Wir sind noch genau in dieser Sweet, Sweet, Sweet Time, wo das völlig okay ist, über unsere französischen, italienischen Nachbarn und Nachbarinnen zu reden. Aber ich glaube, ich schaue es weiter, weil ich mochte einfach diesen Moment dieses Kohlenhydrate oder Protein und der so mir völlig egal. Genauso habe ich mich nämlich gefühlt. Ich war nicht beim Friseur. Fett wollte der vielleicht auch haben. Ja, einfach Fett, geben Sie mir einfach Fett. Das sind die drei Bestandteile, Kohlenhydrate, Protein oder Fett. Sie beschreiben gerade einfach Essen. Genau, Sie beschreiben zwei verschiedene. Also, ja, haben Sie sich schon für was entschieden? Wir haben heute im Tagesangebot, wir haben einmal Kohlenhydrate, dann ganz reingekommen sind Proteine und was auch immer gern genommen wird, ist Fett. Alles klar, das ist dann wie so Subway oder so, wo man so Salatbau, wo man sich zusammenstellen kann. Wie viel Prozent Protein, also das … Genau, ich hätte gern 20 Prozent Fett. Ja, sehr gut. Dann noch 40 Prozent Protein. Wunderbar, alles klar. Und ich glaube einfach 40 Prozent Kohlenrate. Alles klar, wunderbar. Okay, noch was da drauf haben oder so? Ne, das ist ja dann 100% schon, mehr geht ja nicht. Du kriegst halt einfach so eine graue, dünnflüssige, so eine dünnflüssige. Aber der Vorteil ist, man kann es einfach wegwerfen, man kann es in den Laden reinwerfen. Ich trinke es aus und werfe den Teller auf den Boden, ich werfe ihn auf den Boden.
Aber so ging es mir auch beim Friseur, wo dann tatsächlich, ich gehe immer zum selben Friseur, aber jetzt war ein anderer Mitarbeiter und dann zeige ich dem immer die Fotos, zeige ich immer die Fotos, so möchte ich gerne aussehen. Es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe irgendwann mal Fotos rausgesucht, die richtig dumm sind, unscharf, wo ich so von der Seite in irgendeiner Moin Moin mit geschlossenen Augen, aber wo ich das Gefühl habe, da sind die Haare okay. Ich würde so gerne wissen, wie du denkst, dass meine Haare am besten aussehen. Ich kann dir die Bilder zeigen. Gerne. Und dann meinte der so, mit Schere oder Maschine geschnitten? Und ich wollte an dem Moment nicht sagen, jetzt ist es doch ihr Job, das zu entscheiden. So hätte ich eigentlich normalerweise reagieren wollen. Der innere Monolog ist so anstrengend. Ich dachte mir, es ist unklug, jetzt in den ersten zwei Sätzen sich den Friseur zum Feind zu machen, aber ich denke mir schon immer so, das ist nicht mein Job. Anders als bei einem Roadtrip ist hier das Ziel das Ziel. Mir ist egal, wie Sie zu diesem Ziel kommen. Genau, ich zeig Ihnen den schönen Ruteweg, nehmen Sie den Waldweg, nehmen Sie den schnellsten Weg. So wie wenn du in einer Fremdenstein ein Taxi steigst, ah, sollen wir über die Hohenbrückenbrücke fahren oder durch den Gresenlammentunnel. Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe. Das ist mir völlig egal. Du bestellst im Restaurant einen Fisch. Ja, und sollen wir denn irgendwie auch von beiden Seiten grillen oder nur von einer Seite grillen? Das ist mir mega wichtig, wenn Sie solche Fragen stellen. Ja, sorry, Spiegelei, wollen Sie Sunny Side Up? Ja, oder nein, je nachdem, was eure Präferenz ist. Aber es ist doch geil zu wissen, es ist doch geil, ein bisschen mitentscheiden. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich bin da ganz anders. Oder wieder Koch das in den Tendenz. Ich bin da ganz anders. Ja, okay, ich verstehe, ich gehe dir nur nicht, da gehe ich nicht mit. Okay. Ich gehe die halbe Strecke. Da ist der Punkt für dich. Wenn ich mitentscheiden kann, wenn es eine Wahl ist, man kann es entscheiden, Steak, willst du Medium, Rare, willst du Medium, Rare? Ja, okay, bei manchen Sachen gibt es schon Sinn, aber da nicht mehr, da ist es dann einfach gleich, das Ergebnis ist gleich. Was geht schneller im Ideal? Also, genau, Ziel ist das Wichtigste, wie sieht es aus, danach die Geschwindigkeit, wie man zu diesem Ziel kommt. Ja. Wenn das sind, wenn, ja gut, mit einer Schere braucht ihr einfach drei Stunden, ja, dann nehmen sie halt einfach bitte das Rasiermesser. Oder man bricht so ein Dreiecksdiagramm, das alles sich beeinflusst. Also wenn man Schere nimmt, wird es ein bisschen hässlicher, also Schönheit, Geschwindigkeit und Preis. Okay und Preis. Okay und teurer. Also dann sagt man, okay, dann kann man erstmal so einen Raum, so einen kahlen Raum, wo jemand so ein Erpatter sitzt und sagt, okay, also Sie können Schere oder Maschine auswählen. Wenn Sie Maschine auswählen, geht es sehr, sehr schnell. Aber es wird ein bisschen hässlicher. Okay, ja, das ist mir nicht so wichtig. Mir ist Geschwindigkeit wichtig. Also Schönheit, Geschwindigkeit. Dass ich hier zwei Minuten weniger da sitze, aber dafür ein bisschen hässlicher bin. Weißt du was, rasieren Sie mir die Augenbrauen ab. Okay, das ist ein neues Problem, was wir aufmachen. Weg damit. Jetzt wird es Jetzt wird es eher zu einem Hexagon. Jetzt wird das gerade noch sehr anschauliche Dreieck zu einem Hexagon. Naja, aber muss sein, ich gehe sehr ungern zum Friseur, aber muss sein und ja, muss sein, aber sieht toll aus, sieht toll aus. Und das, danke schön, und das Gute ist natürlich, dass man sagt, jetzt muss ich erst mal lange wieder nicht. Ich gehe zum Friseur, um nicht zum Friseur gehen zu müssen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie Sport. Ich mache Sport, um dann zweieinhalb Jahre lang zu sagen, ah, jetzt habe ich ja schon Sport.
The best self zu sein. Ja, genau. Ich, wie ich die Leute gerne verunsichere, ist immer zu sagen, ah, was war ein Friseur, ja, sieht mega cool aus und dann immer im Gespräch halt so hochgucken. Also immer so, weil das sieht man, wenn man die die Achse nicht stimmt, und immer so hochgucken zwischendurch. Und dann irgendwann sagen die Freunde immer, was ist denn jetzt los? Nichts. Wenn man so leicht mit den Augen hochgeht. Man kann die Leute so gut verunsichern mit der Frisur. Frisur ist wirklich, aber du hast zum Beispiel eine pflegeleichtere Frisur draußen in der Witterung bei viel Wind oder so. Meine Haare drehen dann durch und dann habe ich einfach so eine Teddybär, alles steht gleichmäßig ab Frisur. Das ist immer die schlimmste Frage, diese hippen Friseure dann so, und tun sie sonst immer was rein oder so? Produkt? Tun sie sonst Produkt rein? Ich so, nee. Und immer so dieses... Hä? Okay? Aber warum hat man sich da eigentlich geeinigt, Produkt zu sagen und es nicht zu spezifizieren? In allen anderen Dingen des Lebens sagt man ganz, sagt man nie Produkt. Hast du Produkt gekauft? Ja. Kauf Produkt. Ich glaube, das Wort Produkt ist einfach dafür serviert. Nein, sagt man nicht. Man sagt bei allen Dingen klar, was für ein Produkt man kauft. Wenn du Pasta isst, kommt der nicht mit dem Parmesan und sagt, wollen Sie noch ein bisschen Produkt? Passiert einfach nicht. Auf die Pizza noch ein bisschen Produkt drauf?
Wie? Aber in die Haare soll ich noch ein bisschen
Produkt reinmachen? Produkt? Sagst du was?
Ja, es kommt irgendwann was für ein Produkt.
Ja.
Das Produkt oder das Produkt? Es gibt zwei Produkte.
Es gibt viele Produkte.
Welche Produkte?
Alles ist ein Produkt.
Seinfeld.
Ja.
Auch ein gutes Outro, aber ein anderes gutes Outro ist auch...
Leute, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche und macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal.
Haut rein.
Ich sag mal Tschüss, wir heben ab.
Sag ich auch.
Haut rein.
Schließe ich mich an.
Brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Sag mal Tschüss, wir heben ab, haut rein, guten Flug an.